>>Linda: The best activities in
classrooms develop a lot of skills
at one time, both cognitive
and social-emotional.
>>As we talk a lot about the
complex thinking and problem solving
that people need to be able to do in
today's society, in order to do that,
you need the capacity to self-regulate,
to manage your time and your emotions.
You need the capacity of
executive functioning,
to organize how you approach
things, to be metacognitive
and reflective about your work.
These things are developed in
certain kinds of work simultaneously.
>>Cynthia: Creative problem solving is
a skill that we want our kids to have,
and the makerspace is the
place in the classroom
where we're cultivating
that skill in our kids.
>>Carly: I'm supposed to make
something, and it's supposed
to help people, or help fix a solution.
>>Teacher: All right, so
let's go to your design.
>>Carly: She'll get your approval,
so then you can start getting
your materials and make it.
00:01:25,666 --> 00:01:29,336
>>Cynthia: When you give kids
autonomy and choice and really hands
on materials, you have them applying
the learning in a way that helps them
to gain deep understanding.
00:01:37:19 --> 00:01:42,246
>>Linda: If you give children a project
to undertake, a passion that they have,
that they want to find the answer to,
they need to be able
to organize themselves.
They will be using critical
thinking and problem solving,
and as they undertake these tasks,
they're building both the social
and emotional foundation, and they're
also building the cognitive abilities
to demonstrate their learning.
>>Cynthia: It's almost second nature to
them that you keep working on something.
>>Student: I had to turn this a little.
It means it was going the wrong way,
because it's supposed
to go in the middle--
>>Cynthia: We send the message
in everything we do that struggle
and making mistakes are
ways that you can learn.
The makerspace is a physical place
and an approach to problem solving
that really lends itself to that
notion of practice being important.
As you work harder on it, you change
it and improve it, it gets better.
>>Linda: Because of that, they will
feel empowered, with a growth mindset,
to continually get better
in their learning.
>>Student: So time to
take, times things apart.
>>Student: It's called makerspace,
but we call it take apart,
so we can take it apart.
>>Cynthia: When everything we do
is building independence in kids,
building their ability to be
self-regulated, then you can release
to time and interest areas where kids
can go to the makerspace and stay there
as long as they'd like, because
you've built that ability
to be self-regulated while
doing that autonomous work.
>>Student: I'll hold it like that.
>>Student: No, I got it.
This is like a level.
>>Linda: We see children as little
as three years old spending thirty,
forty minutes working on a
project, regulating themselves,
because it's an environment that
both teaches them how to do it,
and is positive and affirming.